good morning and very welcome to the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
welcome back I should say to many of you
who were here yesterday today we're
celebrating chemistry the Academy met in
session this morning and took the
decision on the Nobel Prize in Chemistry
and we have just spoken to the new Nobel
laureates
I'm Jordan Hansen I'm the
secretary-general of the Academy and
with me today is on my right professor
Klaus Gustafson who is the chairman of
the Nobel Committee for chemistry and on
my left
professor Soros noburo Linzer who is a
member of the committee actually its
previous chairman and an expert in the
field of this year's prize and as usual
I'll read the announcement in Swedish
and in English and then the citation
also in German French Russian to cover
all Alfred Nobel's
favorite languages then we'll hear
remarks about the price from Klaus and
an introduction to the science behind
the price by Sora this year's prize is
about harnessing the power of evolution
or its priests Hannah larum of the
masked revolutions crafts congressman
scopes academy nor adobe suite at Attila
xuan roarton ocean well trisomy may in
health until Francis ho Arnold
farik that evolution of a swimmer
a mantra helped and immense until George
P Smith or Gregory P winter for fog
display of peptide or canticle per the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences has
today decided to award 2018 a bell Prize
in Chemistry with one-half to Francis H
Arnold for the directed evolution of
enzymes and the other half jointly to
George P Smith and Gregory P winter for
the phage display of peptides and
antibodies
so wine and health and Francis Arnold
fill the giving state ability on from
and seaman also end up in hell if given
some and George Smith and regular winter
filled us Fagin display from peptide
Anand antica open Puma Chia Francis
Arnold do live allusion to the citizens
in a Pluto multi content more short
Smith a Gregory winter put the phage
display depicted on T cool Francis
Arnold sauna probably no yo evolute see
of ferment of George Smith a Gregory
winter the fog we display petit of the
ante tell and on this slide you can see
some brief biographical data about our
new nobel laureates francis a charnel
was born in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania in
the United States in 1956 and she's
currently at the California Institute of
Technology Caltech in Pasadena in the
Los Angeles area George P Smith was born
in 1941 in Norwalk Connecticut and he's
currently at the University of Missouri
in Columbia in the United States sir
Gregory P winter was born in 1951 in
Leicester in the United Kingdom and he
is at the laboratory of molecular
biology and the University of Cambridge
in England so with that I'd like to ask
close Gustav's on chairman of the Nobel
Committee to make some remarks about the
price cross so thank you your arms so
this year's prize in chemistry rewards a
revolution based on evolution our
laureates have applied principles of
Darwin in the test tube's
and use this approach to develop new
types of chemicals for the greatest
benefit of humankind in the natural
world evolution of proteins has been
around for thousands of millions of
years all the way back until astata life
on Earth instead mutated and proteins
have evolved to improve the
Fitness of this life for thousands of
years we humans have used selected
breeding to create animals and plants
with properties that have been useful
for us this year's Nobel laureates Nobel
laureates have taken the next step they
have used the molecular understanding
that we today have of the evolutionary
process and recreated the process in in
their laboratories in their test tubes
in doing so they have been able to to
make evolution many thousand times
faster and they have also been able to
direct evolution to create proteins with
new and useful properties this work has
led to the creation of proteins with new
and somatic activities able to catalyze
useful chemical reactions in addition
with a method called phage display they
have also evolved protein with proteins
with new binding properties such as
antibodies that can be used to treat
disease in the laboratories our
laureates this year have been able to
direct evolution to steer it which has
led to the need to new chemical tools
that can be used in everything from
environmentally friendly detergents to
the creation of new biofuels and
pharmaceuticals Thank You Klaus Sora can
you give us some insights into the
evolution of enzymes and pages okay
thank you
life on Earth is the result of billions
of years of evolution organisms have
adapted their chemistry to fill Nicias
and environments random mutations in
their genes
lead to changes in their proteins many
of these are enzymes enzymes speed up
the chemical reactions in biology any
changes that are beneficial or do no
harm may be kept for the next generation
for further randomization and testing
during generations to come
evolution has given us an amazing
variety of creatures full of little
helpers enzymes chemists use enzymes to
speed up reactions in their laboratories
in industrial processes and in consumer
products over decades scientists have
tried to improve enzymes using rational
thinking Frances Arnold realized that to
really get somewhere she needed to grasp
evolution and blend in an element of
randomness into the process in 1993 she
published the first example where she
had used directed evolution to improve
the performance of an enzyme
she took the gene for the enzyme
introduced random combinations of point
mutations expressed all these genes in
bacteria that were then producing a
whole library of enzyme variants these
were screened for activity and the best
variants were kept for further rounds of
meta Genesis and screening until a
desired level of performance was
obtained to the left there is a model of
the enzyme that she has optimized in
green the blue is the substrate as the
diagram shows the best variant of the
free generations
of random mutagenesis a screening was
255 times better 256 sorry the times
better than the starting enzyme in red
we see the side chains the positions of
the enzyme that were changed to achieve
this nobody could have predicted this
that this particular combination would
do the job this illustrates the power of
evolution and the element of randomness
Francis Arnold has since used directed
evolution to improve a number of enzymes
for new reaction conditions to conduct
new chemical reactions to take in new
substrate even to make bonds for which
no enzyme is available in nature the
applications are numerous and include
molecules used for brain imaging
biofuels pharmaceuticals the enzymes
used from directed evolution make us a
greener chemical industry where they can
replace more harsh chemical catalysts
even toxic metal ions enzymes derived by
directed evolution are also used to make
high-energy molecules and reaction
intermediates for synthesis now over to
the other half of this year's Nobel
Prize in Chemistry where we award the
fates display of peptides and antibodies
now we get to meet a new little fellow a
bacteriophage this is a virus that can
infect bacteria a bacteriophage is a
protein capsule that encloses the DNA
that codes for its own makeup it fools
the bacterium to produce new copies of
the DNA and all the proteins and spit
out a multiple a multitude of copies of
the infecting phage George Smith
realized that this could be used for
powerful technology
he took a foreign gene placed it inside
the Jane of one of the capsule proteins
so that the encoded protein ended up on
the surface of the bacteriophage this we
call phage display in his first work he
displayed a fragment of a protein this
we call a peptide and he mixed the
displaying pages with a millionfold
excess or other phages and then he
immobilized in jello here the antibody
that's specific for this peptide and
used it to fish out the binding phages
and wash out the rest after this he also
introduced the concept of peptide
libraries where he displayed not a
single peptide but the whole library of
different peptides on pages and when he
used the antibody to fish he could then
get the sequences with highest affinity
for the antibody and determine its
epitope to really use the technology to
derive therapeutic antibodies the face
display has to be done in rivers Gregory
winter took a fragment of an antibody a
fragment here in jello that contains all
the binding parts and managed to display
it in fully functional form at the
surface of the phage again he added a
millionfold excess of other phases and
he could use the target of the antibody
as a fishing hook to pull it out and
remove the non binding ones he then went
on to make libraries of antibodies on
pages and using an immobilized target
you could add a library wash away the
weak binding antibodies extract the high
affinity ones and subject them to new
rounds or diversification and screening
to select better and better antibodies
and over just a few generations he could
obtain very high affinity and very
specific antibodies and this forms the
basis for a pharmaceutical revolution
antibodies produced by phase display are
used to treat this
such as ultra inflammatory diseases and
tracks and cancer and many more are
currently in clinical trials the methods
developed by Francis Arnold George Smith
and Gregory winter or to the highest
benefit of humankind thank you thank you
Sarah I think we may now have one of our
new Nobel laureates with us on the phone
dr. Arnold are you there I am there
hello again this is John Hanson I'm the
guy who woke you up
in the middle of the night it's less
than an hour ago have you had you a cup
of coffee yet so we are sitting now in
the Cession hole of the Academy of
Sciences and here are nearly 100
journalists in total and I'm sure some
of them would like to ask you some
questions so are you ready for them I am
shall we give to my son hey a chance to
start and thank you congratulations
Nobel Prize thank you
we have a paper here with a headline
that says playing with evolution and I
was thinking maybe some something
similar has been said about what you do
earlier and sometimes a phrase like that
could make you suspicious what are you
what are you up to what are you doing
you have you have lots of questions like
that and what do you usually say now we
have some problem with a line I'm afraid
sorry to interrupt but we cannot really
hear you dr. Arnold let's see if we can
do something about it
okay let's try again so please go ahead
okay what a pity the line doesn't work
so much for sophisticated electronics I
wish they were evolutionary developed
enzymes instead yeah no I don't think we
get anywhere wanna give it another try
we can give it one more chance now they
have to save their questions for when
you come here in December thank you so
much for trying to be with us during the
first conference and and and we look
forward to meeting you in December when
you come to receive your Nobel Prize
thank you and bye bye well I'm afraid
you'll have to do with us in the panel
instead the lady over there could you
wait till you get the microphone sorry
could I just see here just sit okay
thank you yes this is Janet one for
notic Chinese times and we noticed that
many of the Nobel prizes in physics or
chemistry during the decades have been
awarded to the findings related to
cancer biology or physiology this this
year's and so my question is could I ask
if how why why are this phenomenon sub
increasing this years and what would the
Nobel Prize Committee suggest in the
future thank you I think we'll ask close
Gustafson to comment on that
so I there is no sort of real intention
from our side to sort of focus on on
these subjects that you
bring up I could be true if you go back
to that there could be some pattern
there I think it has to do with the fact
that you know Alfred Nobel he wanted a
price that was for the greatest benefit
of humankind so it had to have
consequences for for for for people for
humans and I think that because we're
always looking at both brilliant science
but also brilliant science with with
sort of consequences and maybe that's
why you can see that some of the prices
are related to the area which you allude
to thank you so much
I think these findings are really
inspiring and Mulder's thank you good to
hear it good to have you with us more
questions yes the gentleman from
Associated Press thank you so I
understand that you spoke with the
laureates would you be able to tell us a
little bit how they reacted have you
managed to speak to all of them and how
was their initial reaction when when you
told them the good news yes we spoke to
all three of them and they were all very
happy and enthusiastic and exhilarated
they look forward to coming here in
December and they were also happy to
share the price with their colleagues so
it was all positive reactions we spoke
with with Greg winter first and then
with Francis Arnold and then last with
George Smith and dad they were all
delighted yes please passion opera from
those Newton I wonder if there are any
patterns in this field that have
economic significance for
pharmaceuticals or other products sorry
would you like to answer holds a whole
range of patents in science that make
biofuels for example if so you can now
make fossil free fuels for cars and
airplanes based on her technology from
what substances yeah from from different
grown substances it's not yeah it's not
taken out of the fossil reserves so
renewable resources
I think she holds something like 10 to
15 patterns I am not aware of the exact
number and Gregory winter also holds
patents for some of the antibodies that
are derived by the face display
technology thank you
more questions this is your chance yes
please thank you I'm sufficient access
zone from green pulse and China radio
I'm sorry I I like to ask you to use
simple words to explain short how
significant their discoveries are I'd
say very significant but I can start a
chance to say something more the first
half the significance one significant is
that you can now use enzymes to speed up
in principle any reaction you want using
these protocols and you can derive
enzymes that we place previous toxic
catalysts in industrial processes so I
think it has a very huge significance
and the second half makes it possible to
derive fully human antibodies using the
face display these libraries are now
composed of fully humanized antibodies
from the
adapted and they can be made to be very
high affinity and specificity so that
you can use very small amounts in
treatment so perhaps if I had safer
greener chemistry and antibody drugs
worried better efficiency and less side
effects more questions yes please
gentleman over there are there any
potential damages and these research is
like such as creates super species could
be damaged humankind so so there are of
course with all science there are of
course risks but when you think about
the science that we talk about here it's
sort of heavily regulated by you know
it's in modified microorganisms and or
or or used all over the world in in in
in different labs and we use them today
to produce things like insulin for
example treating millions and millions
of people so so this is that there is a
rule-based system that is a
well-established and that regulates this
work also then of course evil minds can
always do things with with technology
but but I don't see any particular
dangers with this price compared to many
other things more questions if not thank
you very much and we'll close this press
conference and there will be individual
interviews thank you very much
Sarris no get up in this year's price is
for engineering proteins can you tell us
work hard couplings yes I like that
question proteins are molecules what are
large molecules that you find everywhere
in your body they conduct almost all the
processes that go on the memory the
thinking the coagulation the muscles
they are really the workhorses in our
bodies because in the body some of the
proteins we have or other organizers
have are enzymes that speed up chemical
reactions but there are reactions we
want to do in chemical synthesis or to
produce fuels that those enzymes can't
do so we have to improve them enzymes
produced by Francis Arnold this year the
price and that is to make the enzyme
conduct new chemical reactions or better
they react as they do today
and the other half is about improving
binding protein so these are produce
that's attached to something and conduct
Spira logical processes by this means
for example antibodies and this
technique can then be used to produce
human antibodies again
pathogens or other substances to come
back to the main method in both prices
so to say use you were talking about
evolution and when we think about
natural evolution you think it's often
described as a combination of chance and
necessity is this what they do yes this
is I would say a combination of chance
and necessity but also quite a big
element of thinking because what they
have done is to really speed up the
evolution this nature has had billions
of years but now you want the process to
be possible in maybe a few weeks or a
year or something in the laboratory
random experiments and then picking up
the right parts of it yes I would say in
nature is what a random process because
the mutations happen by chance may be
due to UV radiation or something whereas
in the laboratory it was a combination
of knowledge based so you have to you
have to have some idea of which
positions to bury but then you add a
random mess on top of that so the
biggest difference would be that you
know what goal you have while in nature
actually the risk may be you know I
would say made you has no goal but what
works works and everything that makes
things better
or that you can populate a new gate
niche is then kept whereas in the
directed evolution the scientist defines
the goal I want to break this bone or
make this bond and I want to make it as
quickly as possible at 58 degrees or
whatever is the condition yes the
scientist define the condition
and one of the Prize laureates Francis
Arnold she knew she wanted enzymes what
why couldn't she designed them from the
beginning it's very good question and
scientists also try to do that and in
principle we know which kind of
intermolecular forces operate in
proteins but I think the problem is that
it's a multi cognate oriole problems
it's still not possible with the
knowledge base message today to design
an enzyme from scratch one can design an
some that have some catalytic efficiency
but to really really get somewhere you
have to bring in the power of evolution
to optimize them can you tell us
something about who is Francis Arnold I
think she is a very good and very
talented scientist a very curious
scientist and also goal-oriented she
knows what she wants to do and then she
sets out to do it also the other prize
Lawrence George Smith he designed the
metal with this page this way which is
hard to understand what it is but it's a
method to produce antibodies yes so the
way he designed a method it took those
pages that are these protein capsids
that have the DNA inside the codes for
making the capsid and what he did we put
in the gene for the protein he wanted to
study and he then sort of fooled the
phage to put it on its surface so this
is what we call phase display on the top
on the bottom depending on how you turn
them around but at the tip of the phage
yes
and I think the key element of his
technology that really made it fly was
this physical linkage between the gene
and the protein product so that you
could fish out stages and then take out
the DNA and work further with new
generations of variations and Gregor
winter used it to produce antibodies but
what is special about antibodies
the special thing with antibodies I mean
it's a part of our the immune defense
these are proteins that makes you have
designed to have a possibility to become
very specific so the face technology
harness is the power antibodies have six
different loops in each binding pockets
that it can vary and this is ideal in
fact put on a page and the random with
the journalist is to search for very
high affinity antibodies so they can
have very high affinity and high
specificity for a certain molecule and
not not react the others and then they
can be used to make drugs drugs because
they can either bind to objects or
surfaces we have in the body or they can
bind to things that we try to invade us
how many drugs have been produced from
this metal I actually don't know but I
know that of the 50 most soul drugs on
earth eleven are made by this method are
they very expensive I'm not sure they
are very expensive but the advantage
with the face display is that you can
derive antibodies with such high
affinity much higher than you get real
immunization that you can lower the
doses you can use much lower doses you
can even use them cutaneous on the skin
you don't have reject them so there are
many advantages we know
so what do you thing is next was what is
the vision for the future the vision for
the future thing I think we were just at
the start I think we will see many more
enzymes that catalyze bonds that we had
no clue that an enzyme could actually do
one of the latest examples from honors
lab or enzymes that catalyze the
formation of carbon silicon bonds and
these are bonds you don't find in nature
and there is no natural enzyme but she
managed to take one and evolve it to
form these kinds of bonds that are
important for making materials for
example thank you very much sir little
clean set for being here
you